joe biden continues to reiterate that
he'll pick a black woman which again is
kind of insane the reason it's insane is
because in any other context that would
just be racist if he said i need a white
male that would be racist if he said i i
need an asian
transgender
little person that would also be sort of
strange
labeling people not by their belief
system about the constitution but by
their race and sex seems kind of
counterintuitive when your entire shtick
is that you're supposedly an anti-racist
but of course we know that the ibramex
candy anti-racist folks are the most
racist people in america today here's
joe biden pushing this
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to the united
states supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
i made that commitment during the
campaign for president and i will keep
that now i'm just going to point out
right here that joe biden did vote
against clarence thomas's nomination to
the supreme court on the basis of the
ridiculous hill accusations also his
party filibustered the woman who
certainly would have been the first
black woman on the supreme court janice
rogers brown when george w bush wanted
to nominate her for the ninth circuit
court of appeals it was the it was the
democrats who attempted to filibuster
janice rogers brown they did the same
thing with hispanic american miguel
estrada when it came to the dc circuit
court of appeals so all of their
affirmative action nonsense to the side
the reality is what they mean is a
person who believes like we believe but
also is going to fulfill certain
intersectional check boxes so i can go
back to my constituents and i can
pretend that i care deeply about them
that's what this is really about now the
amazing thing is that the media
immediately went to full spin mode and
you could see that this was going to
happen because as soon as joe biden had
said i need a black woman everybody on
the right went okay that's affirmative
action and a violation of basic equal
protection standards like an employment
if i just said today i'm only hiring a
producer who is a white male i will not
look in any other candidates this would
be a violation of equal protection it
would also be a violation
of the civil rights act of 1964 i'm not
a government actor so it wouldn't
technically be an equal protection
violation it would be a civil rights act
violation okay but he's a government
actor which means he's violating both
it doesn't matter the media immediately
has jumped into action to suggest that
republicans are pouncing it's just it's
all about republicans pouncing so you
have aaron blake writing for the
washington post here's the title the
very selective effort to cast biden's
supreme court pick as an affirmative
action hire wait hold on i don't have to
cast it as that he said it
he literally said it
i mean i don't know how else am i
supposed to take i need the first black
woman
am i supposed to take that any like does
he not need the first black woman
you'll notice at the beginning of this
particular episode i put the phrase
black woman in air quotes the reason i
put that in air quotes is because that's
a joe biden quote
like it is affirmative action i don't
know what else to tell you
i mean they quote me saying it is
definitionally affirmative action and
race discrimination which of course it
is
but then aaron blake goes on he says
well you know there have been other
presidents who have done this yes and it
was bad when they did it ronald reagan
promised he would appoint a woman to the
supreme court in the 1980 presidential
campaign and then he ended up appointing
sandra day o'connor who was a joke and a
terrible justice
george h.w bush picked clarence thomas
but clarence thomas happens to be a
really really good justice
okay the fact that that we have these
sort of designated seats is ridiculous
it's ridiculous on its face
it's really stupid
and meanwhile jen saki is suggesting
that the gop is obliterating their own
credibility by criticizing biden's pick
well no we are criticizing him for
saying that he will only look at the
race and sex of a person as a as a
predominant characteristic and also we
think that you're just gonna select a
democratic apparatus who's gonna do
whatever you want because that's what
you guys do again democrats never miss
on this stuff because they just find
somebody who agrees with them
politically and then appoint that person
to the supreme court knowing they don't
care about the constitution
we have not put out a list uh the
president made very clear he has not
made a selection uh and there are if
anyone is saying they plan to
characterize whoever he nominates after
throw consideration with both parties as
radical before they know literally
anything about who she is uh they just
obliterated their own credibility man
talk about obliterating your own
credibility gensake every single that
should be the the title of her
autobiography obliterating my
credibility gen saki story
wow
and by the way speaking of obliterating
your credibility it is fairly incredible
that they are now attempting to go after
ilya shapiro he's been a guest on this
program of course he is from cato
institute
and now he is uh he's about to be a
lecturer at georgetown university what
did he do wrong he said quote
objectively best pick for biden is sri
srinivisian who is solid progressive and
very smart even has identity politics
benefit of being the first asian slash
indian american but alas doesn't fit
into the latest intersectional hierarchy
so we'll get a lesser black woman thank
heavens for small favors the fact that
he used lesser black women they're now
saying that he's racist what he meant is
a black woman with lesser credentials
obviously
but um you know it
none of it matters they're trying to
basically oust him from his position
over at georgetown anyway
so you have a guy named mark joseph
stern who's tweeting out he says that
georgetown law has hired him so i feel
an obligation to condemn him there's a
staff writer at slate trying to get ilya
shapiro canceled from his job because he
is making clear that these
the that the biden administration is
picking somebody who's not well
less qualified at least than than the
person that he described there
again affirmative action for democrats
and it only works one way it's not
affirmative action when they do it even
if they say it's affirmative action
meanwhile we all know the real reason by
the way that they they somehow convinced
justice briar to step down the real
reason they convinced them to step down
is because they're about to get walloped
there's a brand new poll out of out of
georgia today
from the atlanta journal constitution
and the university of georgia and it
finds governor brian kemp right now up
on stacey abrams by seven points despite
all the controversy surrounding camp
even senator perdue the ex-senator he
beats stacey abrams by four meanwhile in
the senate herschel walker is up three
on senator rafael warnock
47-44 and according to polling data
actually only 21 of georgians say that
an endorsement from trump would make a
candidate
more attractive to them only 21
say that it would make a candidate less
attractive to them now you assume that
that includes you know all the democrats
but here's the bottom line
if you look at the the approved versus
disapproved ratings for various members
of the georgia delegation
they're not great for the democrats
assemblies at 43 warnock is at 44. biden
is at 34.
so things are likely to get extremely
ugly for rafael warnock in georgia
before things are over meanwhile in
nevada it looks like things are really
ugly by the way it is also true that the
democrats have now engaged in precisely
the same strategy that
donald trump engaged in in the georgia
election earlier this year so george you
remember donald trump after he did not
win georgia after that happened he came
out and he said that was because of
voter fraud and your vote really doesn't
count in georgia and a bunch of
republicans stayed home for the senate
elections which is why you have now two
blue senators from a red state
and that was because donald trump
intervened and people from the rural
areas did not vote in that senatorial
election which is a foolish move now
democrats are like hey let's do it too
apparently according to a new quinnipiac
poll 45 percent of black voters in
georgia think it will be somewhat or
very difficult to vote
okay now how many believe that in 2020
seven percent
seven percent seven percent of black
democrats sorry not black democrats
seven percent of black voters in georgia
total
said
that they thought it was very difficult
to vote in 2020. now 45 say it is very
difficult to vote how many of those
people are going to stay home just
because they believe it's difficult to
vote so brilliant strategies here from
the biden administration just genius
genius
stuff
it is incredible how this administration
just keeps shooting itself directly in
the foot over and over and over again
you know if you shoot yourself in the
foot you shouldn't be surprised when
your foot hurts and that's exactly what
is happening right now and they can't
stop won't stop i mean biden's surgeon
general literally came out yesterday and
said that he wants joe rogan censored by
big tech like i'm sorry this is not the
way you win hearts and minds here gang
we've got to do several things number
one we've got to recognize that our
technology platforms whether
particularly social media these have an
important role to play these are the
predominant places where we're seeing
misinformation spread these platforms
have still not stepped up to do
the right thing and do enough i should
say to reduce the spread of
misinformation this is not just about
entertainment it's not just about
garnering clicks this is about people's
lives and we have seen time and time
again that misinformation costs people
their lives so you have the surgeon
general of the united states calling for
censorship of joe rogan you keep going
with this guys you have your narratives
your nerves are completely at war with
the experience of the american people
keep trying to convince them not to
believe the evidence of their own eyes
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang